actually has occupied this application
nuclear power change in southern Ukraine
since March and attached troops in
military equipment there and in recent
days in Russia reports hello
as benches two weeks in Montana and less
than a week sleeping in an actual house
and in that short time I was confronted
with an uncomfortable but kind of
undeniable truth
my life is more balanced and I feel more
creative when I'm in a house
I know this because I'm an
organizational freak and I keep a very
detailed calendar slash journal and
whenever I'm in a house my work ethic is
solid
out on the road my calendar looks more
like a patchwork quilt of Van chores
unforeseen detours and sporadic blocks
of dedicated work
it's organized chaos at best
in a house so much is taken off my plate
I'm able to relax and give more time and
energy to all the ideas swirling around
in my head
even something as simple as doing
laundry I can easily start it and forget
it whereas on the road I need to route
through a city find a laundromat and
wait two hours for my clothes to wash
and dry
and yeah there are ways to be productive
in between all the chores and errands
and driving but I personally find it
challenging to do anything more than
repetitive surface level tasks
I do my best creative work during long
stretches of uninterrupted time and
total solitude which means I'm usually
driving to remote places with as much
water and food as my van can hold
ing I'll find internet and a quiet place
to base
but out here on the road
anything can happen
earlier this summer my electrical system
melted then Chipmunks invaded my upper
cabinet detached while driving down a
bumpy road
last week my water pump broke and
yesterday my heater started cranking out
error codes now what
I don't know what I'm doing
no I don't know if I were my own
employee which I technically am it would
totally fire me what the heck the
weather here is so sporadic imagine if I
had to call my boss every day and be
like oh
um
I know I was supposed to work this week
but ended up having to drive four hours
away just to get sun and then you know
since I was passing through a city do
all my chores yeah
but my pump broke so I also have to like
hang around this one area until the part
ships and unfortunately like
I just I don't have service
[Music]
what do I do
[Music]
the number of times I've had to relocate
or change plans because of the weather
or because I didn't feel safe or have
enough solar or service or desperately
needed a shower
easily more than a few hundred times in
my four and a half years out here
nope I'm not here to complain
it's just that lately I've been turning
this lifestyle over on all sides trying
to decide if the lows are still worth
the highs after all this time
and right now
I'm not so sure
this is the real van life endless
decision after decision after decision
after decision forever and ever amen
Welcome to My Life
foreign
thereon is reinforcing this my toilet
drawer which is always kind of like on
the brink of falling apart so there's
this two by six here and then
reinforcing with the screw here
and yeah hopefully that'll fix it I'm
gonna use these stainless steel screws I
think it'll look I think that it's gonna
look nice even if you didn't paint it
so we're also moving the handle down for
it to be flush has to be three and a
half inches
or we might put it lower
so that it doesn't put so much stress on
the drawer
what do you do
[Music]
so this setup is basically the dream you
can drive your van right in here and
then have tools to fix stuff up there's
bed Loft up there bed loft there washer
dryer bathroom shower little kitchen
literally
so perfect for Van life when you just
want to like relax
and yeah
not have to move around all the time
plus this one
comes with a really cute dog
hey Maddie
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hiking
in Grizzly country
heading up to
I was not hoping no one else is there
because we did not bring a tent
[Music]
oh my gosh
wow
I feel like I just ate a pie
CE
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
look at this View
this is where I'm sleeping tonight
it was janky but wow this is incredible
wait what are you shooting through the
hole Yeah I can only see your shoe oh
you're safe
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this may I'll be entering into my sixth
year of living full time on the road
which is so wild to even say out loud
let alone actually live
I think this whole experience can best
be described as an endless roller
coaster of highs and lows the kind
without any clear end or beginning
because the ride never stops
it just goes round and round until one
day you unbuckle your seatbelt and
launch yourself into the unknown
probably not so different from all the
times I've returned to the states after
living abroad
there's a kind of reverse culture shock
that you experience after being gone for
so long
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
the idea of leaving the road is scary if
I'm being honest
like I'm afraid I've forgotten how to
exist in the real world
as if I somehow just don't belong
because I think living on the road
rewires your brain in a way
it trains you to expect the unexpected
and to embrace the unknown
it forces you to cultivate patience
flexibility and heightened ability to
problem solve and perform under pressure
you also learn to trust your intuition
read situations and make your own
decisions
and also probably what I would consider
the most valuable of all
you develop a deep well of internal
gratitude
questions
thank you
[Music]
the road teaches you to clearly Define
what you truly love and that which
allows you to grow
while also teaching you a really
difficult lesson of letting go
[Music]
who let go of a lot literally a lot of
your things have to be donated stored or
sold
but beyond that you sacrifice stability
convenience community
everything requires more time research
and planning
living on the road was a dream of mine
for years before I finally took a risk
to turn that dream into a reality
and now I find myself dreaming of having
my own home
a place to unwind in between month-long
stretches on the road
and I'm trying to dig deep and find the
courage to make that leap
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I left Montana feeling that whatever
comes next whether I decide to stay on
the road or not
my decision doesn't have to be final
the road isn't going anywhere
it'll always be there waiting for you
for me for anyone who feels that
undeniable pull to shake free and just
disappear into the wild for a little
while
which is packed up
close all the windows heading back down
so epic up here
as I sit here editing this I feel a
sense of direction I haven't had for a
long time
and even though I don't know exactly
where this road will go
I don't really mind traveling the scenic
route
taking the Long Way Home
[Music]
ready
oh my gosh
[Music]
so pretty holy
holy crap I live for it
foreign
[Music]
when you're just like wow how is this my
life
how is this my life
I've been feeling that a lot lately
[Music]